[Music]
[Music]
after a long hiatus i welcome you all
back to the final episode of the hero's
path
the seven part mini-series which covers
the various journeys of hyrule's most
prominent characters
on the day of the great calamity with
hyrule warriors age of calamity now
right around the corner
i think it's about high time we finish
this series up with grace
if you haven't watched any of the
previous episodes i highly recommend you
start by watching part 1 about link and
zelda first as that one sets the stage
which all subsequent episodes build upon
today we cover the most prominent member
of the hylian civilization
which is none other than the king
himself rome bosphorous
hyrule now unlike all the other
characters we've covered so far
king rome is the one we actually have
the least amount of information for
both in terms of the game itself as well
as creating a champion
the scenarios you find in this video are
solely based on the little information
we do have
environmental hints from the game itself
and the most prominent theories derived
from it
fittingly enough my guest speaker for
this final episode is none other than
celtic
who first proposed a solid theory about
the king's fate which is still regarded
as one of the most plausible scenarios
to date a link to that video will be in
the description
aside from that this is also a
collaboration so make sure to head over
to zeltek's channel and check out his
latest video
with that said let's finish things up
with a bang
[Music]
the story of hyrule's monarch on the day
of the calamity begins at hyrule castle
while his daughter is on her pilgrimage
to the spring of wisdom
king rome himself awaits her return with
hopes of good news in regards to
unlocking her sacred power
a quest which so far remains fruitless
at hyrule's capital life continues as
usual
armed guards patrol the perimeter goods
are purchased and sold
politics discussed and the sheikah
continue their research into the ancient
relics in the courtyards of hyrule
castle
however around sunset the piece is
abruptly disturbed
a maelstrom of violent red clouds dark
in the air over the settlement
together with lightning bolts tearing
through the skies above
and from the depths of hyrule castle
itself an ominous spectre arises
soaring around the peaks of hyrule's
royal home
after years of preparation and prophecy
the day of ganon's return has finally
arrived
confident that the champions will adhere
to their duties and make their way to
the divine beasts as soon as possible
rome orders his knights to get ready to
fight alongside the sheikah's
technological wonders
as the royal guards prepare to defend
their king with their lives
this is what they prepared for in the
many years leading up to this moment
they are ready to subdue calamity ganon
the same way that their ancestors from
10 000 years ago did so successfully in
the past
but ganon gannon is cunning
what the leaders of the kingdom didn't
account for was that the calamity gannon
wasn't about to fall for the same trick
twice and instead has its own strategy
in place to foil the hylian's plan
with a deafening roar the demon king
releases numerous strands of malice
aimed at the very technology which was
designed to suppress it
before the hylians and chica realise
what has just happened
their precious machines spring to life
eyes
burning with the eerie glow of ganon's
hatred
in the blink of an eye the thriving
hyrule castle
is turned into nothing more than a
slaughterhouse with guardians cutting
down
anything in their path without
hesitation five
giant pillars which were rumored to
reside somewhere in the depths below
hyrule castle
yet had eluded the research teams
despite vigorous excavations
rose up from the ground as if reacting
to ganon's presence
each one pouring out more guardians to
do his bidding
but the cruel fate of hyrule castle its
guards
advisors poets and so many more
is only the beginning from this point on
ganon's newfound army is set on
only one thing destroying the kingdom of
hyrule
and everyone in it
unlike most of the characters we've
covered so far the fate of the last king
of hyrule
is one that is in large part left up to
our imaginations
the game itself never makes any
suggestions as to his fate beyond the
fact that he lost his life during the
calamity
creating a champion does have some
mentions but the information itself can
be quite contradictory
some parts hint that he died as soon as
the guardians besieged hyrule castle
other sections suggest that he may have
survived at least until the divine
beasts were taken over which doesn't
happen
until later down the line if the former
turns out to be the case
that would mean the video ends right
here king rome dies at the castle
the end however there are hints that
rome may have played a bigger role
during this fateful day
the biggest clue we have that suggests
the king's possible escape
is the location of his grave on the
great plateau which in the actual
in-game
files can be found under the name field
object king's tomb
a if he did die at the castle it's
unlikely that his body would be found
amidst all the chaos and patrolling
guardians
not to mention carried all the way to
this remote mountaintop
so let's sketch the most likely
alternative scenario instead
if king rome did indeed manage to escape
from hyrule castle there is a chance
that this might be a playable section
where the king with the delegation of
his best knights and royal guards fight
their way out of the castle
and into castle town all the while
trying to buy enough time for some of
the civilians to escape the turmoil
armed with his royal claymore the king
could fight his way from the castle onto
the town square
and from there he will eventually make
his way onto the fields of central
hyrule
rome commands the lion's share of his
army at hyrule castle to escort the
surviving population through the east
gate and following the road towards
akala citadel meanwhile he and his
delegation set out for hyrule garrison
since link and zelda entered the castle
through the main gate it's possible that
they may have run into the king
and it was he who ordered his daughter
to make her way to the safe haven at his
[ __ ] rico village
in the meantime rome himself takes
responsibility for the defense of
central hyrule and exits castle town
past the sacred ground mabe village and
towards hyrule garrison
the first true line of defense to the
south of the castle
unlike the ranch the quarry and mabe
village which are mostly occupied by
civilians
soldiers are stationed here and it shows
the ruins of hyrule garrison are
littered with dead and incapacitated
guardians
indicating that the forces stationed
here fought back valiantly
in war even an inevitable defeat can
still serve as a small victory and the
battle at hyrule garrison will prove to
be an important one
this defense could serve as a gameplay
section for the king
since if you remember from lincoln
zelda's journey an evacuation line was
set up from the hyrule exchange
located right below hyrule garrison all
the way towards hateno village
it's highly likely that if rome was
indeed present at the defense of hyrule
garrison
it was none other than him who ordered
it while he and the soldiers fight back
the hordes of guardians rushing from the
main capital they buy the evacuees some
time to get as many to safety as
possible
the defense at hyrule garrison won't
last for long however
with more and more guardians pouring
into the fields of central hyrule
the stronghold will eventually be
overrun and the royal knights and guards
under the command of their king will
have to abandon their efforts and
retreat back to the foot
of the great plateau and the many
outposts located alongside it
here the defense of the evacuation line
continues and it's possible that this is
an extension of the gameplay scenario
mentioned earlier
but this effort too will do nothing more
than buy some additional time
the sheer amount of guardians and their
technological superiority
can only be held back for so long this
defensive line too will
eventually fall the majority of the army
stationed at the outpost will accompany
the evacuees towards nekluda to ensure a
safe passage
meanwhile rome and the leftovers of
central hyrule's army retreat further
back
onto the great plateau itself and
towards the temple of time
and eastern abbey the ruins of the great
plateau reveal that its entrance a grand
staircase leading up to the plateau has
completely collapsed
and in the 100 years following the
events of the calamity flooded with
water
turning it into a small pond though it
is never confirmed
many have speculated that the collapse
of the entrance may have been the
hylians doing
and even creating a champion makes a
reference to this stating that it's
possible that the gate leading to the
great plateau may have been blocked to
hinder any further
guardian incursion the demolition of the
plateau's grand staircase gives a clear
insight into just how
dire the situation was that day
demolishing the only entrance to their
most holy of sights
essentially cutting themselves off from
the rest of the kingdom
here king rome and his forces prepare to
make their final stand against ganon's
central army
the soldiers stationed themselves at the
temple of time
while a small sub-group of them get
ready to defend the monks at the eastern
abbey
at the temple of time archers are
stationed on the upper floor
overseeing the fields below additionally
soldiers are stationed inside the three
buildings in front of the temple
to absorb the first wave of automata
rushing in
if these structures are eventually
overrun the surviving forces will be
able to retreat back
up the staircase and into the main
building given his importance as the
monarch of hyrule
king rome himself is likely stationed
inside the main building as well
under the protection of whatever is left
of his royal guards
while the hylians prepare for their
final stand guardians
claw their way up the walls of the great
plateau the destruction of the main
entrance
only bought them some extra time to
prepare although we never see the
guardian stalkers climb in the actual
game
probably just for gameplay reasons we
know for a fact that they
are able to ascend even the steepest of
walls
this is evident from one of the first
cutscenes in the game
the memory of a hundred years ago told
by the spirit of king rome himself
here we can see one of the machines
scaling a church at a 90 degree
angle as the guardians reach the top of
the great plateau's walls
they rush towards the temple of time
with no hesitation
as archers let loose volleys of arrows
in an attempt to slow them down
the three frontal buildings are quickly
overrun though some of the soldiers
stationed here did manage to take out
some of the machines before retreating
up to the main structure
hordes of guardians slam into the walls
of the temple of time like
waves on rock attempting to claw their
way up to reach the upper levels of the
compound
the narrow entrance to the temple likely
prevented the large-bodied guardians
easily
accessing the inside with the advantage
of their elevation
the archers successfully managed to keep
the machines at bay
who by this point are piling onto one
another in a desperate attempt to scale
the walls of this holy site
with more and more dead guardians piling
up
they'll need to find a way inside the
structure sooner or later
the front of the temple has thick and
sturdy walls
however the ruins of the temple of time
reveal its greatest weakness
the eastern wall as well as its rooftop
it's possible that the guardians circled
around to the side of the building and
concentrated their combined firepower on
this section
alternatively ganon could have even used
one of the corrupted divine beasts
aiming its devastating laser at the
temple and blasting away the eastern
wall
with the temple now breached the
guardians are now free to enter at will
wiping out the remaining survivors held
up inside
the eastern abbey has also come under
siege and although its ruins reveal a
courageous defense
with many guardian corpses littering its
interior and exterior
the abbey too is ultimately lost along
with its inhabitants
so that's it right with the guardians
now having free reign over the temple of
time
this undoubtedly signals the death of
king rome as well
well there is one additional piece of
environmental storytelling which could
hand towards one final desperation
attempt to get rome to safety
remember this is the king of hyrule
we're talking about
the soldiers and guards of the kingdom
are tasked to protect his majesty's life
at all cost it's possible that when the
temple was breached from the east side
the king and some of his guards snuck
out through the main entrance to flee
towards the mountains to the west
the reason why this might be the case is
because alongside the river of the dead
close to the bridge crossing into the
mountains we find
two additional dead guardians lying in
front of what seems to be the ruins of a
gate
there is no reason for guardians to be
present here since there are no other
hylian strongholds or settlements
situated in this area
of the plateau nothing beyond the temple
of time and eastern abbey
this could very well be the exact
location where the king
ultimately met his demise they fled
towards the mountains from the temple of
time
until they were finally cut down by
pursuing guardians
taking two of them out in a last effort
to save their beloved king
this could explain why rome's grave is
located on the top of mount hilia as
opposed to closer to the temple of time
whoever discovered his body here in the
snowy fields may have decided to carry
him across the bridge and up to mount
hailia and make this
his final resting place the death of the
king and the many soldiers and guards
who stood their ground at the great
plateau
officially marked the fall of central
hyrule considering the odds against them
they still managed to put up a fight
worth remembering aside from akala
citadel and fort hatteno
the temple of time in its surrounding
area houses one of the greatest numbers
of dead guardians in the entire kingdom
a true testament to their valiant
efforts even in death
the king of hyrule was not at ease not
until he made sure that his kingdom
would one day
see its revenge on the scourge of hyrule
castle
his daughter zelda who sealed herself
inside the walls of his former home
requests him to watch over the plateau
in her absence to relay an important
message
when the time comes unable to rest the
king's spirit will wander the
ruins of the deserted battlefield that
is the great plateau
waiting for a blue-eyed young man to one
day step back
into the sunlight
[Music]
you